christian for you so obviously 2021
now marks 20 years
since smallville premiered why are you
saying that because it's blowing
my mind it has to be blowing your mind
yeah i mean i haven't thought about that
but yes
it's been 20 years wow
two decades yeah that's crazy
wow cake
yeah i made cake the other day somehow
what is he saying though that's like
that's a lifetime that
is it's a total child it could be two
it's a multiple
children 20 years anywho the point of
this
is will we see a cast reunion or
something special for the 20th
anniversary are you guys in a group chat
are you staying in touch with anybody
can you send your text
i we definitely are in touch i feel like
we we've we've done lots of stuff in the
last few years i don't know if they'll
be like a big i don't know if anyone's
talked about like a big 20th
year thing because i think everyone's
avoiding the reality that it's been 20
years
but but i don't know
once the pandemic's over i'm sure we'll
all be together at some
convention somewhere and we can
celebrate how old we are
again at that point